Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安（Marianne）。在深入今天的节目之前，我想快速告诉大家一个现在正在发生的激动人心的消息。如果你曾想过如何创造为你源源不断带来收入的管道，而不是把时间无休止地出卖给金钱，那么你一定会喜欢“冲刺经常性收入挑战赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge），这是由我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入流。无论你是一个有志成为心理学家的人、心理健康从业者，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. 74% of all suicides in the UK are men. But why is this happening? And more importantly,
这些原则都同样适用于你。此外，还有由丽莎本人直接送出的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）一对一交流一小时的辅导。你想了解更多吗？你当然想。前往我的 Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），或者查看我的社交媒体渠道，或者给我发个简短的私信，我就会把所有详情发给你。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。在英国，所有自杀身亡的人中，男性占了 74%。但为什么会发生这种情况？更重要的是，
what can we do to change it? In this very special magazine style episode, I am joined by three people who can talk with us and help educate us about three very high risk areas for men. The first is Lee, an ex-marine who now works in the building trade. Our next is Sharon, a researcher and farmer's wife, who has a really good overview of farming life and farming community. And last but not least, I'm joined by Charlie, the CEO of Men's Sheds UK, whose organisation is all about transforming lives by giving men a safe space to get connected, feel supported and build meaningful connections. This episode is more than just about understanding the problem. It's about finding real, practical,
我们能做些什么来改变它？在这个非常特别的杂志风格节目中，我有幸邀请到三位嘉宾，他们将与我们交流，并帮助我们了解男性面临的三大高风险领域。第一位是李（Lee），他是一名退役海军陆战队员，现在从事建筑行业。我们的下一位嘉宾是莎伦（Sharon），她是一名研究员兼农场主的妻子，对农场生活和农场社群有着非常深刻的了解。最后但同样重要的是，我邀请到了英国“男士棚屋”（Men's Sheds UK）的首席执行官查理（Charlie），他们的组织致力于通过为男性提供一个安全空间来建立联系、感受支持并建立有意义的人际关系，从而改变他们的生活。这一集不仅仅是为了理解这个问题。它是关于寻找真正、实际、
workable solutions for reducing suicidality in men. Whether you're directly affected or looking to support someone who is, I hope that you find this to be a crucially important conversation. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent, a qualified clinical psychologist. Now in the UK, it is more common for women to be diagnosed with depression. And yet, of course, as our intro revealed, it is men who are higher in the suicide rates with 74% of suicides in the UK in 2022 being males. It's often discussed that there are certain industries that do seem to have a higher rate of suicides. So I really wanted to use this space to explore that, to empower you, to help you think about questions, to ask people that may be around you. And I think this is really important because sometimes we might feel like we don't have the necessary knowledge. We don't know
切实可行的解决方案，以减少男性的自杀倾向。无论你是直接受到影响，还是希望支持受影响的人，我都希望你发现这是一场至关重要的对话。嗨，欢迎来到“有志心理学家播客”（Aspiring Psychologist Podcast）。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。在英国，女性被诊断出患有抑郁症更为常见。然而，正如我们的开场白所揭示的那样，自杀率更高的反而是男性，2022 年英国的自杀者中有 74% 是男性。人们经常讨论的是，某些行业似乎确实有着更高的自杀率。所以我真的很想利用这个空间来探讨这个问题，赋予你力量，帮助你思考一些可以向周围人提出的话题。我认为这非常重要，因为有时我们可能会觉得自己缺乏必要的知识。我们不知道
what to say. We don't want to say the wrong thing. So by watching this, hopefully this will help you feel like you are enough and you know enough to point somebody in the right direction and to instill a sense of hope. You may notice as this episode progresses, there's various different stages of Marianne because it's been recorded across the summer. One point I have a mole, then I have a bandage on my face, now I've got a wound. Stick with it and you'll get the flow of what was recorded when. These are really important conversations to have and I wanted to get our experts booked in and get these interviews recorded. I've previously chatted to Lee, not on the podcast, but in a social media conversation around about the pandemic time. He
该说些什么。我们不想说错话。所以通过观看本期节目，希望这能帮你觉得自己已经足够好，并且掌握了足够的知识，能够将某人引导至正确的方向并注入希望感。随着本期节目的推进，你可能会注意到不同阶段的玛丽安看起来有些不同，因为这是在整个夏天断断续续录制的。有时候我脸上有一颗痣，然后我脸上贴了块纱布，现在我脸上有了一个伤口。坚持看下去，你就会顺着录制的时间线理解前后的脉络。这些都是非常重要的对话，我想把我们的专家约好，把这些采访录下来。我以前和李聊过，不是在播客上，而是在大约疫情期间的一次社交媒体对话中。他
is so brilliant and inspiring. I love chatting with Lee. So let's dive in. Let's meet him. And I will catch you on the other side of this. Hi, Lee. Welcome along to the podcast. Thanks for having me on, Marianne. I appreciate it. Thank you. I always love speaking with you and since we last spoke um you've had a change of your business you were previously working in fitness um and you from an ex-military background but you are now working um in quite a different area you've really taken control and you're doing something very different now aren't you what are you doing now yeah well basically yeah i went from being a raw marine to owning a boot camp fitness business
非常出色，充满启发性。我很喜欢和李聊天。所以让我们深入探讨吧。让我们认识他。节目后半段见。嗨，李。欢迎来到播客。谢谢你邀请我来，玛丽安。我很感激。谢谢。我一直很喜欢和你交谈，自从我们上次交谈以来，呃，你的业务发生了变化，你以前从事健身行业，而且你有前军事背景，但你现在从事……一个完全不同的领域，你真的掌控了自己的生活，现在做着非常不同的事情，不是吗？你现在在做什么？是的，基本上，是的，我从皇家海军陆战队员变成了经营一家训练营健身业务的
uh covid sort of saw the end of that um a bit of a long story but yeah covid was the end of the fitness business and i now find myself um operating a crane, installing steel beams for builders on building sites every day. So, yeah, a bit of a contrast from what I was doing before. Very different. I know from following you on socials and from our chat beforehand, this is really invigorating for you. You're really enjoying it. And you're a father, you're a father you're a husband and this is really helping to to help you do all the things you love to provide for your family but also your own mental health yeah that's it exactly um when the when the fitness business came to an end as you know it's a bit of a long story i know we're limited for time i'm sorry i'm going to do too much but yeah i've always been conscious of my my mental health i had a few
嗯，新冠疫情算是让这一切画上了句号，虽然说来话长，但是的，新冠疫情结束了我的健身业务，我现在发现自己……每天在建筑工地上操作起重机，为建筑工人安装钢梁。所以，是的，这和我以前做的事情形成了鲜明的对比。非常不同。我从关注你的社交媒体以及我们之前的聊天中了解到，这对你来说真的很振奋人心。你真的很享受。而且你是一位父亲，你是一位父亲，你是一位丈夫，这真的在很大程度上帮助你做所有你热爱的事情，为你的家庭提供经济支持，同时也对你自己的心理健康大有裨益。是的，完全是这样，嗯，当那个健身业务结束的时候，如你所知，这说来话长，我知道我们时间有限，抱歉，我不会说太多，但是的，我一直对自己的心理健康保持清醒的认识，我经历过一些
issues to say the least when i was a bit younger so since then i've always been you know really keen to prioritize my mental health and i understand that your job what you do for a living what you get up out of bed and go and do for eight hours a day, nine hours, sometimes more, can have a massive impact on your mental health. If you don't enjoy what you're doing, it can impact your mood and your energy. You go home, you take that mood and energy home with you, it then starts to impact your relationship, your parenting, your diet, and then all this has a bit of a snowball effect and it can be uh
至少可以说不小的心理问题，当我稍微年轻一点的时候。所以从那以后，我一直……你知道的，非常热衷于把我的心理健康放在首位，我明白你的工作、你谋生的手段、你每天早上起床去干上八个小时、九个小时甚至更长时间的活，会对你的心理健康产生巨大的影响。如果你不喜欢自己做的事情，它会影响你的情绪和精力。你回到家里，把那种情绪和精力也带回家里，然后它就开始影响你的夫妻关系、你的育儿方式、你的饮食，接着所有这些产生了一种滚雪球效应，这可能是……
obviously detrimental to say the least so yeah when i was looking for something to do after my fitness business i gave it a huge amount of thought and to be honest that was one of the main sort of priorities really is or was finding something that i I thought I'd be happy doing, I'd enjoy doing, so that I took home at the end of each working day a positive energy into my house. As you mentioned, I'm married. I've got a lovely wife. I've got four beautiful little kids.
至少可以说是非常有害的。所以，是的，当我寻找健身业务结束后的出路时，我进行了大量的思考，说实话，这是主要的优先事项之一，或者说是寻找一份……我认为自己会乐在其中、会享受的工作，这样我在每个工作日结束时，能把积极的能量带回我的家中。正如你所提到的，我结婚了。我有一个可爱的妻子。我有四个美丽的小孩子。
And I didn't want to come home in a foul mood and let that foul mood affect everybody else. It's just something that, to is super super important yeah I think what I love about what you've done is that you know you've demonstrated that actually you can do a career change at whatever stage of your life you know I know that you had young twins at the time when this was happening as well and you're like well this is the right time for. And this is going to be giving me the chance to live my authentic self, you know, in my family and to have the kids grow up with a happy dad, really. That's what was important to me.
我不想带着糟糕的心情回家，让那种糟糕的心情影响到其他人。这对我来说是超级超级重要的一点。是的，我觉得你所做的事情最棒的地方在于，你证明了其实你可以在人生的任何阶段实现职业转型。我知道当时你还有年幼的双胞胎，你当时也面临着这种情况，你觉得“嗯，这就是对的时机”。这将给我一个机会，在我的家庭中过上真正的自我，让孩子们在一个快乐的爸爸身边长大，真的。这对我来说才是最重要的。
You know, don't get me wrong, I love my dad to bits. He was a brilliant dad and he worked so, so hard to provide for me and my sister and put a roof over our heads, put food on the table. But I didn't know at the time, but looking back, I understand he was under a lot of pressure. He didn't particularly enjoy what he was doing. For example, my dad, he used to work in a factory all day. And he used to say that in the winter, he didn't see sunlight. He'd get up really early in the morning, go to the factory,
你知道的，不要误解我，我非常爱我爸爸。他是个出色的爸爸，为了养活我和我姐姐、给我们一个遮风挡雨的地方、让我们有饭吃，他工作得极其努力。但我当时并不知道，现在回想起来，我明白他承受着巨大的压力。他其实并不怎么喜欢他做的事情。比如我爸爸，他以前整天在工厂上班。他常说，冬天的时候他根本见不到阳光。他一大清早就起床，去工厂，
work all day, do overtime. By the time he'd come out, it was pitch black again. He hadn't seen the sunlight all day. Then he'd come home and he'd start fixing cars. He was good with cars. And I remember him, he'd be lying in our back entry at home in the snow on his back underneath the car, welding cars. He was brilliant in that respect.
工作一整天，加班。等他出来的时候，天又黑得伸手不见五指了。他整天都见不到阳光。然后他回到家，开始修理汽车。他很擅长修车。我记得他会躺在我们家后门入口处的雪地里，仰面躺在车底下，焊接汽车。在这方面他真的很厉害。
But at the same time, not all the time, sometimes it didn't take much to set him off. He'd lose his temper, start shouting and swearing and banging the table and all the rest of it. I want to be keen know keen i'm keen not to sound like i'm bad mouthing my dad i'm not because i understand what pressure is under you know i'm getting something getting up and doing something that you hate all day coming home and lining the snow welding cars i can understand why he used to lose his temper a bit
但与此同时，也不是一直这样，有时候不需要费多大劲就能惹恼他。他会发脾气，开始大喊大叫、说脏话、拍桌子等等。我不想……你知道的，我不想让人觉得我在说我爸的坏话，我不是这个意思，因为我理解他承受的压力。你知道的，做着一件你整天都讨厌的事，回家后还要躺在雪地里焊接汽车，我能理解他为什么有时会发点脾气。
sometimes but i was just keen to you know as a as a father now myself not to not to repeat that pattern yeah absolutely it really it really reduces your window of tolerance when you are not vibing of what you're doing I don't think I'm young enough or cool enough to say vibing but there you go I've gone for it I've said it um it really does it really does change your outlook and it changes your capacity to do all of your roles, all of your responsibilities, but also to just do you. Yeah, that's it.
但我自己作为一个父亲，很想……不想重复那个模式。是的，绝对的。当你对正在做的事情没有共鸣时，你的容忍度确实会大大降低。我觉得我还不够年轻、不够酷，不能用“共鸣”这个词，但不管怎样，我还是用了，我说出来了。它确实如此，它确实改变了你的视野，改变了你履行所有角色、所有责任的能力，同时也改变了做真实的自己的能力。是的，就是这样。
You can't do something that you hate all day and then come home to your family and be all happy and cheery and play with the kids and have some banter with your wife and read stories and output you know, output bedtime. You can't do all that stuff if you just come home miserable and you want to just open a beer and a bag of crisps and sit on the sofa and binge watch YouTube videos or whatever. You know, if you do something you quite enjoy all day,
你不能整天做着自己讨厌的事，然后回到家里对家人表现得高高兴兴、开开心心，跟孩子们玩耍，跟妻子开开玩笑，读读故事，应对……你知道的，应对小孩子睡觉。如果你回到家里只是闷闷不乐，只想开一罐啤酒、吃一包薯片，坐在沙发上狂刷油管（YouTube）视频之类的，你是无法完成所有这些事情的。你知道的，如果你整天做着自己相当享受的事，
you come home and you're in a positive mood and you're ready to be that husband you you're ready to be that husband and you're ready to be that father that you know i aspire to be and probably a lot of men aspire to be but they find it difficult because they're they're slugging away at something they don't particularly enjoy all day well done to you that's absolutely yeah i'm so pleased that you found that and that you're achieving that for your family um with your experiences of the building trade you know i'm very aware that there's a very high demographic it's not a very nice term but of high suicide rates in the building trade and i'm also aware you know that
你回到家里就会保持积极的心态，随时准备好成为那个丈夫——你随时准备好成为那种丈夫，随时准备好成为那个我渴望成为的父亲，大概也是很多男性渴望成为的父亲，但他们发现这很难，因为他们整天都在为自己并不怎么喜欢的事情苦苦挣扎。真为你高兴，绝对的。是的，我很高兴你找到了这一点，并为你的家庭实现了这一点。结合你在建筑行业的经历，我非常清楚，建筑行业存在着一个很高的人口统计比例——这不是一个很好听的词——也就是建筑行业很高的自杀率。我也意识到，
within that there'd be a wide spectrum of people from kind of jobbing 16 17 year olds learning trade and doing kind of bricklaying and scaffolding apprenticeships and stuff right up to company owners you know this is a big scope of people that we're kind of discussing here what's your take on why the rates for suicide are so high in this industry Lee? I've got to be honest Marianne I was actually shocked when I found this out because I entered the construction industry I'm not I wouldn't call myself a tradesman because I just basically operate a crane at the end of the day and install steel beams but I'm still in the construction industry and I entered it because I thought it would be good for my mental health and it actually is I love it I'm outside all day I'm getting plenty of sunlight it's physical what
在这个行业里，存在着广泛的人群光谱，从刚开始学习手艺、做砌砖和脚手架学徒的 16、17 岁的年轻学徒，一直到公司老板。你知道的，我们在这里讨论的人群范围很大。李，你认为这个行业的自杀率为什么这么高？说实话，玛丽安，当我发现这一点时，我其实很震惊，因为当我进入建筑行业时——我不会称自己为建筑工人，因为我归根结底只是在操作起重机和安装钢梁，但我仍然身处建筑行业——我加入进来是因为我认为这对我的心理健康有好处，而它确实如此。我很喜欢它。我整天都在室外，能晒到充足的阳光，我做的是体力活，
I do so it's I'm getting a form of exercise um I'm with the lads all day you know I don't want to be politically incorrect but I just love working in a male-dominated environment um it's a little bit dangerous you have to stay switched on otherwise you know potentially I could get hurt or somebody else could get hurt so when I decided to take this route I thought to myself when was the happiest time of my life work-wise and it was when I was in the in the Royal Marines so I thought okay when I was in the Marines what what was it that made me happy and like I said it was being outside it's doing physical stuff dangerous stuff I have to stay switched on being with the lads having a bit of a bit of you know banter and you know good laugh and taking
所以我得到了某种形式的锻炼。我和小伙子们在一起呆一整天。你知道的，我不想显得政治不正确，但我就是喜欢在一个以男性为主导的环境中工作。这有点危险，你必须保持高度警觉，否则，你知道的，我可能会受伤，或者别人可能会受伤。所以当我决定走这条路时，我问自己：“我职业生涯中最快乐的时光是什么时候？”那是在我加入皇家海军陆战队员的时候。所以我想，好吧，当我在海军陆战队员时，是什么让我快乐？就像我刚才说的，是在室外，做体力活，做危险的事，必须保持高度警觉，和小伙子们在一起，开点玩笑，你知道的，开怀大笑，互相开玩笑损对方，所有诸如此类的事情。
the mickey out of each other and all that kind of thing. So that's why I joined the construction industry because I thought it would be very, very similar. And I'm loving it. But since we spoke the other week, and then somebody else actually mentioned to me that the construction industry has a high suicide rate. I just got to try to think, like, why is that? Why is it that I'm loving it?
这就是我加入建筑行业的原因，因为我认为它会非常非常相似。而且我很喜欢它。但自从我们上星期谈过之后，后来另一个人也对我说起过，建筑行业有着很高的自杀率。我一直在想，这是为什么？为什么我会这么喜欢它？
And don't get me wrong, a lot of the builds I speak to, they say they love it, say they enjoy it. So I know, you know know obviously it can be enjoyed um but yeah giving it some thought i've come up with a few things um the first thing that occurred to me is perhaps that what i do is is very very varied i go to a different building site every day meet a different bunch of lads i've got a different problem or a different set of problems to overcome i'm traveling sort of all over the midlands and the northwest so i'm i'm seeing a bit of the countries i'm driving around meeting different people i may be if you haven't got that variety if you're just turning up on a
别误会我，我聊过的很多建筑工人都说他们很喜欢，说他们很享受，所以我知道，你知道的，这显然是可以被享受的。但，是的，经过一番思考，我想出了一些原因。首先映入脑海的是，也许我所做的事情非常非常多样化。我每天去不同的建筑工地，遇到不同的一群小伙子，要克服不同的问题或不同的一组问题。我在米德兰兹和西北地区到处奔波，所以我能看到一点这个国家的样子。我开车四处转，遇到不同的人。如果你没有那种多样性，如果你只是每天出现在
building site every day and laying a thousand bricks you. You go home, go to bed, get up the next day, go back to the same building site, lay another 1,000 bricks, and that's your life, you know, week in, week out, just laying perhaps a lack of variety. And I'm just using the brickies as an example. I'm sure there's other areas of the building industry where there is that lack of variety. So that was the first thing that came to my head.
建筑工地上，铺一千块砖。你回家，睡觉，第二天起床，回到同一个建筑工地，再铺一千块砖，这就是你的生活，周复一周，可能就是缺乏多样性。我只是拿泥瓦匠举个例子。我相信建筑行业的其他领域也存在这种缺乏多样性的情况。所以这是我脑海中浮现的第一件事。
Second thing I've noticed is a lot of building sites I go to, and I'm not trying to be judgmental here, but their diet is atrocious. It's all Greggs. I don't know if I'm allowed to name names. Sorry if I'm not allowed to name names, but it's all gregs definitely to name names sorry if i'm not adding name names but it's basically fast food junk food you know bags of crisps bottles of pot etc etc um and i think a lot of people don't understand the relationship between the food that we eat sugars refined carbohydrates all the chemicals that they put in processed food
我注意到的第二件事是，我去过很多建筑工地，我不是想在这里妄加评判，但他们的饮食简直糟透了。全都是格瑞斯（Greggs，英国知名连锁饼店）。我不知道我能不能点名。抱歉，如果我不能点名的话，但基本上全是快餐、垃圾食品、
these days a lot of people don't understand the link between that and their mental health so i think a lot of builders will probably benefit from cleaning cleaning their diet up um obviously there's a bit of a drinking culture a lot of builders they'll go for a few beers on the way home or they spend all weekend having a few beers drinking basically and as you know obviously alcohol is a is a depressant doesn't do you any good from a from a mental point of view so if you're you know sort of combining all this oh and another thing i've thought about as well is um his status I found a little bit that if you if you basically you're walking around in a suit or you know you've got a laptop case like a briefcase for example or you're you know perhaps when I was a PT in a tracksuit or a vest I was
一包包薯片、一瓶瓶汽水等等等等。而且我认为很多人并不理解我们吃的食物、糖、精制碳水化合物以及现代加工食品中添加的所有化学物质之间的关系。很多人不理解这与他们的心理健康之间的联系，所以我认为很多建筑工人可能会受益于改善他们的饮食。显然，这里还有点饮酒文化，很多建筑工人在回家的路上会去喝几杯，或者整个周末都在喝几杯，基本上就是喝酒。如你所知，酒精显然是一种抑郁剂，从心理角度来看对你没有任何好处。所以如果你把所有这些结合起来，哦，还有一件事我也想到了，那就是
looking in shape people look at you differently. Whereas if you've got work boots on and you're covered in mud and you're soaking wet and you've got all muck all over your face and your hair's everywhere, I don't know. You know, there's like a – I don't know what the word is. I don't know if stigma is the right word. But I think some people in society can sort of lock down on workmen, on tradesmen. You know, I remember at school or somebody said to me the other day, actually, that when they're at school,
社会地位。我发现了一点，如果你基本上是穿着西装走来走去，或者你知道的，手里拿着一个像公文包一样的笔记本电脑包，或者你知道的，也许当我还是私人教练（PT）时，穿着运动服或背心，看起来身材很好，人们看你的眼神是不一样的。而如果你穿着工作靴，浑身是泥，湿透了，脸上全是污垢，头发乱蓬蓬的，我不知道。你知道的，有一种——我不知道哪个词是对的。我不知道“污名”是不是合适的词。但我认为社会上有些人确实会看不起工人、技工。你知道的，我记得在学校时，或者前几天有人对我说，其实他们在学校时，
the teachers used to say, if you don't try hard, you'll end up working on a building site. And there's that sort of, so I don't know if some lads in the in the trades feel like they they lack a bit of status in society i don't know this is i'm just trying to um you know i'm not trying to trying to offend anybody i'm just trying to i think you're right you know i think i can remember that sort of being said and threatened and around and and maybe you know what we know is that perhaps people that do find formal education more tricky are more likely to end up in kind of hands-on manual labor professions and so maybe there are more people that are perhaps struggling with some of the interfacing of kind of modern life and yeah keeping up with everybody else and the shame and stigma
老师常说：“如果你不努力，最后就会去建筑工地上干活。”有那种——所以我不知道行当里的有些小伙子是否觉得自己在社会上缺乏一点地位。我不知道，我只是想……你知道的，我不是想冒犯任何人，我只是想……我觉得你是对的，你知道的，我记得这种话以前确实经常被当作威胁和评价挂在嘴边，也许你知道的，我们所了解的是，那些觉得正规教育更棘手的人更有可能从事动手操作的体力劳动职业，所以也许有更多的人可能在挣扎于如何融入现代生活、
um maybe people are ending up in the building trade who who didn't thrive in school or didn't find it the easiest or weren't supported optimally to to overcome dyslexia to kind of think about adhd all of those kind of different things that make engaging in education trickier yeah yeah i'd just like to say at this point i think there's a massive difference between academic intelligence people that can read books and sort of memorize it and regurgitate it or even you know understand it hopefully there's a big difference between academic intelligence and practical intelligence and common sense i work on some building sites and you can tell that they're a very, very good builder.
跟上其他所有人的步伐，以及伴随而来的羞耻感和污名。也许那些在学校里没有蓬勃发展、或者觉得学校不容易、或者没有得到最佳支持去克服读写困难、去理解多动症（ADHD）以及所有这些让参与教育变得更加棘手的事情的人，最终进入了建筑行业。是的，我只想在这时说，我认为学术智能——那些能读书、能死记硬背并把它们复述出来甚至理解它们的人——与实践智能和常识之间存在着巨大的差异。我在一些建筑工地上工作，你能看出他们是非常非常好的建筑工人。
And some of the things I see them come up with to overcome problems, to get these steel beams in, and all their work is immaculate. You know, they've got a really neat, tidy, clean site. And you can just tell that they're very, very proud of their professional capabilities. And I can almost guarantee a lot of these lads, they're fantastic builders, carpenters, electricians, plumbers, all these kinds of people.
我看他们用来克服问题、把这些钢梁装上去的方法，还有他们所有的工作都无可挑剔。你知道的，他们有一个非常整洁、干净、清爽的工地。你一眼就能看出他们对自己的专业能力感到非常非常自豪。我几乎可以保证，这些小伙子中的很多人都是出色的建筑工、木工、电工、水管工，所有这类人。
They're very, very skilled. And a lot of the work they do is dangerous and it's hard work and it's in unpleasant conditions. Oftentimes you're cold and wet. And when I think back on the attitude to these guys when I was at school by the teachers, not all of them, obviously, but some of the teachers, and the way, like I say, sometimes society
他们技术非常高超。他们做的很多工作都很危险，是苦力活，而且是在令人不快的环境中进行的。通常你又冷又湿。当我回想起上学时老师对这些家伙的态度时——当然不是所有人，但有些老师——以及那种，就像我说的，有时候社会
looked down on tradesmen, the work some of these guys do in, like I say, unpleasant conditions, hard graft, it's, you know, I take my hat off to them. And I think a lot of tradesmen should recognise the contribution that they make to society. You know, where would we be without these guys? You know, they build their houses, they fix their houses,
看不起技工，而其中一些人在我说的这种不愉快环境、辛勤劳作中做出的工作，你知道的，我对他们肃然起敬。我认为很多技工应该认识到他们对社会的贡献。你知道的，如果没有这些家伙，我们会在哪里？你知道的，他们建造了我们的房屋，他们修理我们的房屋，
they fix our roofs, you know, any pipes start leaking, your lights go out, you know, these guys will come out and they'll fix it for you. And I think they need to give themselves a pat on the back for that and understand they do a lot of things that these more academic people just couldn't do or wouldn't want to do. I hear you. And today we've had someone out to look at our guttering.
他们修理我们的屋顶，你知道的，任何水管开始漏水，你的灯灭了，你知道的，这些家伙会赶来为你修好它。我认为他们需要为此拍拍自己的肩膀以示鼓励，并明白他们做了许多那些更具学术性的人根本做不到、或者根本不愿意做的事情。我懂。今天我们刚好请人来看了我们的排水沟。
So exactly that. And my husband was like, I could do it. It's got to the stage where he's going to be 49. And he's like, it's going to be really hard for me to do that. Like, I think we should get someone. And I was like, yeah, I totally support that. Like, you know, I think you're absolutely right. Yeah, these guys fulfil a vital role.
所以正是如此。我丈夫说：“我能做。”但已经到了他快要 49 岁的阶段了，他说：“我做那个会非常吃力。我想我们还是找个人来吧。”我说：“是的，我完全支持。你知道的，我觉得你绝对说得对。”是的，这些家伙发挥着至关重要的作用。
Absolutely. We'd be lost without them, and they need to give themselves some credit for that. It's just a different type of intelligence and aptitude and common sense, you know. And some of the lads, like I say, Blame It On Some, the things they come up with, their problem-solving abilities
绝对的。没有他们我们会迷失方向，他们需要为此给自己一些认可。这只是不同类型的智能、天赋和常识，你知道的。有些小伙子，就像我说的，归咎于某些人，他们想出的点子、解决问题的能力，
and the pride they take in their work and the things they construct is fantastic. I think you could be the difference that makes a difference here, Lee. I feel like more sites need to be run by compassionate leaders like you are and like you would be kind of pointing out actually i can see that you struggle with xyz but this is incredible like you should be really proud of this and just try and help lift people up and see themselves as an asset as doing good things not perhaps looking at a deficit looking at things they can't do.
以及他们对工作的自豪感和他们建造的东西真是太棒了。我觉得你可能会成为带来改变的那个人，李。我觉得更多的工地需要由像你这样富有同情心的领导者来管理，就像你会指出的那样：“其实我能看出你在某个地方挣扎，但这真的很了不起——你应该为此感到非常自豪。”只要试着帮助人们振作起来，让他们把自我视为一种资产、在做好事，而不是可能只看到缺点、看到他们做不到的事情。
Yeah, yeah, that's it. So say if you got the lads and they started understanding how sort of valuable they are and what skill sets they've got and understanding that's actually, you know, they're a massive credit to society. If you sort of change their mindset in that respect and if they clean their diets up a little bit and maybe cut down on the boozing and maybe did a bit of exercise or what was the other thing I mentioned?
是的，就是这样。所以，比方说，如果这些小伙子们开始明白自己有多么有价值、自己拥有什么技能，并明白实际上，你知道的，他们是社会的巨大功臣。如果你以这种方式改变他们的心态，如果他们稍微清理一下饮食，也许减少酗酒，也许做点运动，或者我刚才提到的另一件事是什么？
Yeah, maybe added a little bit of variety. If they get a bit bored laying these bricks or do get a bit bored doing this or that, how can I add a little bit more variety into my job? Then perhaps, like I like say those things over individually or combined could um yeah could improve their mental health and you know maybe do something about the the suicide rate I don't know yeah amazing I love those ideas and actually if anyone's listening to this and thinking well I've got a builder coming into clinic next week these are really good examples to be able to discuss with them but also really empowering them to think about well
对，也许增加了一点多样性。如果他们在铺砖时觉得有点无聊，或者做这个那个觉得有点无聊，我该如何为我的工作增加更多多样性呢？那么也许，就像我说的，这些事情单独来看或结合起来，可以……是的，可以改善他们的心理健康，你知道的，也许对自杀率做点什么，我不知道。太棒了，我喜欢这些想法。事实上，如果有人听到这里并心想：“好吧，我下周诊所有个建筑工人要来。”这些都是非常好的例子，可以用来与他们讨论，同时也真正赋予他们权力去思考：“如果我们能做出改变，那会是什么样的？什么才算够了？如果你明天醒来时不再有这种感觉，需要发生什么改变？”而他们可能会借鉴你所说的话，比如：“实际上，这个工地、我干了五年的这份工作，无法点燃我的激情。”然后他们可能会带着一个以问题为导向的叙事来找你：“我不能换工作，因为我离退休还有 10 年，”或者“我找不到别的工作了，别人也不会要我，”或者“我落得这份工作只是因为我一毕业就进来了。”挑战这一点吧。
if we could make a change you know what would that look like what would be enough you know if you woke up tomorrow and you didn't feel like this what would need to have changed and it might be that they're kind of drawing on what you've said like actually this site this job that I've been in for five years it's not igniting me and you know they might then come kind of with a problem focused narrative of I can't change my job because I'm 10 years away from retirement or um you know I won't find another job or no one else will want me or you know I've only ended up in this job because I came in from school and you know challenge that
你知道的，我知道我们可能会把自己局限在一个狭小的格子里，但我相信改变和康复有着无限的可能性，你知道的，我们能够过上成功、快乐、充实的生活，而且我知道你也有同感。是的，绝对的。嗯，就像我说的，我在工地上时确实试着和小伙子们聊聊天。我确实对他们说：“有很多建筑工人说他们从离校就开始干这个了。”我问：“你喜欢它吗？”
you know I know that we can kind of pigeonhole ourselves but just I believe in infinite possibility for change and rehabilitation and that you know we we can we can live successful happy fulfilling lives and I know you feel the same way. Yeah, definitely. Well, like I say, I do try and talk to the lads when I'm on site. And I do say to them, I've only been a builder, a lot of them say, since I left school. I say, do you enjoy it?
就像我说的，他们中的很多人——我会说其中大多数人——都说：“是的，我爱死它了。”现在，你必须记住，其中有些人可能在撒谎，因为很多人都会说“是的，我爱死它了”，即使他们并不喜欢。但确实有些人会说——很多人会说“是的，我爱死它了”，即使他们并不喜欢。但有些人确实会说：“我恨透了，我不能……”我就会说：“好吧，那你为什么还一直干？为什么不做点别的？”“我做不了别的，我一离开学校就干这个了。”我觉得在那个时候，我不觉得那是我的立场去试图指导他们、说教他们或者试图交谈——你知道的，在那样的环境下，我觉得这真的不是我的立场去试图帮助他们，或者试图引发一场职业转型。我在那儿是为了安装钢梁并努力工作以获得……你知道的，生活。
And like I say, a lot of them, I'd say the most of them say, yeah, I love it. Now, you've got to bear in mind, some of them might be lying, because a lot of people will just say, yeah, I love it, even if they don't. But some of them do say, I a lot of people would say yeah i love it even if they don't but some of them do say i hate it i can't say yeah but i say well what why do you why do you keep doing it then why don't you do something else i couldn't do anything else i've done this since i left school and i don't feel at that point i don't feel like it's my place to try and coach them or lecture them or try and talk you know it's not my place really I don't think in that in that environment to to to try and help them or you know try and instigate a career change I'm there to install the steel beam and work to to get you know a life
我听懂了。但我想你的意思是，他们不一定经历过这样的成长环境——让他们意识到你在工作中可以过得非常非常快乐，热爱它，并且，你知道的，几乎像唱歌一样赞美它。你知道的，也许如果他们是在那种环境下长大的——就像你一样，你爸爸其实并不真的喜欢他的工作，他并没有从中获得成就感，然后他基本上只能靠周末活着，你知道的。如果建筑工地上的其他人也有过这样的经历，然后他们自己也去经历了同样的经历，是的，他们就会发展出那样一种信念：这就是工作本来的样子，在退休或死去之前，这一切都只是苦差事，这并不是特别
yeah I hear you but I guess what you're saying is that they haven't necessarily experienced an upbringing where they realise that you can be really, really happy in your job, and love it and, you know, sing about it almost like, you know, perhaps if they've been raised in an environment like like you were where your dad actually didn't really like his job, and he wasn't fulfilled by it. And then he kind of had to live for the weekends, really, you know. And if other people on building sites have had that experience and then go on to have the same experience themselves yeah they kind of develop that belief that this is just what work is and it's all just kind of drudgery really until you retire or die and that's not particularly
充满希望，对吧？不，就是这样。我想你会同意我的看法，如果你不同意就纠正我，但我认为要拥有良好的心理健康，其中一部分是乐观。你需要能够带着一种乐观感去展望未来六个月、未来五年、未来十年、未来二十年或三十年。你需要对未来充满期待，而如果你在未来中能看到的只有每天醒来去面对自己讨厌的事情，那么显而易见，常识告诉我们这对你的心理健康是没有好处的，仅仅是向前看却又不想去做。我从海军陆战队员变成了健身房老板，再到起重机租赁公司老板。
hope filling is it no that's it i think you know i hope you'll agree and correct me if i'm wrong but i think to have good mental health i think part of it is is optimism you need to be able to look at the next six months the next five years the next 10 years the next 20 or 30 years with a sense of optimism you need to be looking forward to your future whereas if you all you can see in your future is getting up every day and going to something that you hate obviously you know common sense dictates that that isn't good for your mental health just looking forward and not wanting to do it i've gone from marine to fitness business owner to crane hire business owner.
而且，你知道的，如果有人听到这里并产生共鸣，看看我就知道了。我刚刚从一件事出发，做出了极端的转变走向另一件事，然后我又做了一次。我在家里有婴儿、非常年幼的孩子、四个非常年幼的孩子、要付的账单和房贷以及所有这些事情的情况下做到了这一点。我不是说这很容易。
And, you know, if anyone's listened to this and it resonates, just have a look at me. I've just gone from one thing, made an extreme move to another, and then I've done it again. I've done it with babies at home, very young children, four very young children, bills and mortgages to pay and all the rest of it. And I'm not saying it's easy.
其实非常非常难。这很有风险。你会失眠很多。你的焦虑水平会上升。这是一个艰难的过渡期。但在我看来，你知道的，我已经坚持了 18 个月，直到最近大概四五个月，
It's not. It's actually very, very hard. It's risky. You'll lose a lot of sleep. Your anxiety levels will go up. It's a difficult transition. But in my opinion, you know, I've been going 18 months and it's only just really in the last maybe four or five months
才刚刚开始步入正轨，我的压力和焦虑水平才开始下降。我只是在其中投入了大量的心血。就像我说的，很多失眠的夜晚，当情况有点紧缩时会有很多焦虑。但你必须对自己说：“好吧，我是想在接下来的 10 年、20 年、30 年里做自己讨厌的事情，还是想对自己有一点信心，
started to get established and my stress and anxiety levels have started to come down. I've just had to put a lot, a lot of hard work into it. Like I say, a lot of sleepless nights, a lot of anxiety when things are a bit tight. But you've just got to think to yourself, right, do I want to do something that I hate for the next 10, 20, 30 years, or do I want to have a bit of confidence in myself,
冒一些风险，经历一两年的压力期，过渡到另一件我会享受的事情——希望会享受的事情？”然后，你知道的，权衡这一切，也许，你知道的，受到启发做出放手一搏的决定，为了你自己的心理健康、你自己的幸福，也为了你的婚姻、你的孩子和更广泛的人际关系而权衡。绝对的。
take a few risks, and maybe go through a bit of a stressful year or two, transitioning into something else that I'll enjoy, hopefully enjoy. And, you know, just weighing it all up and maybe, you know, being inspired to make the decision to go for it, you know, for the benefit of your own mental health, your own happiness, but also the sake of your marriage, your kids, and your wider relationships and just weighing on. Absolutely.
而且，你知道的，人们不必独自承担这一切。他们也可以尝试争取财务支持。你知道的，比如和银行经理谈谈，提出一个方案，真正为之制定一份商业计划，说明你将如何赚钱，并在这一过程中让自己变得快乐得多。非常感谢你，李。我非常喜欢和你交谈，我认为这些是非常非常有趣的观点，我希望这能激励那些从事心理健康工作的人，也激励那些可能正在
And, you know, people don't have to do this alone. They can kind of try and get financial backing as well. You know, like speak to bank managers, you know, put a case forward to kind of really put a business plan together for this and how you're going to earn that money and, you know, in the process make yourself so much happier thank you so much Lee I've loved speaking with you and I think these are really really interesting points and I hope this will inspire people working in mental health but also those who might be
听这个节目、心想“哦，那是我，我没意识到自己在工作中应该感到快乐”的人。人们可以在哪里联系到你？你的 Instagram 是什么？是的，在 Instagram 上，我的“钢梁吊装工”（Steel Beam Lifter）账号是：Steel Beam Lifter Midlands and Northwest（米德兰兹与西北钢梁吊装工）。也可能是 StillBeamLifter Mid and Northwest。所以，是的。我们会确保它显示在 YouTube 屏幕上，
listening to this who are thinking oh that's me I didn't realize I was supposed to be happy in work where can people connect with you? What's your Instagram? Yeah, on Instagram, my StillBeamLifter Instagram is StillBeamLifter Midlands and Northwest. It might be StillBeamLifter Mid and Northwest. So, yeah. And we'll make sure it's on screen on YouTube
并且会放在节目介绍里。老实说，李，我很喜欢和你交谈。这真是一种特权。谢谢你抽出晚上的时间来做这件事，因为我知道时间是如此宝贵。不客气。而且，是的，再次感谢你邀请我来。谢谢。
and that it's in the show notes. Honestly, I've loved speaking with you, Lee. It's been a real privilege. And thank you for taking the time out of your evening to do this because I know time is so precious. You're more than welcome. And, yeah, thanks again for asking me on. Thank you.
哦，李有多棒啊？老实说，和他的聊天真是一种真正的乐趣，我发现这非常振奋人心。再次感谢他在忙碌的工作日后抽出时间与我交谈。所以我们已经开始了解其中的一些问题可能是什么，以及它如何让你感觉相当困顿，实际上，相当受压迫、相当根深蒂固，以及它如何开始让人觉得没有多少希望。
Oh, how great is Lee? Honestly, chatting with him was a real pleasure and I found it so uplifting. And thanks again to him for taking the time out to speak with me after his busy day at work. So we're already getting an idea of what some of the problems might be and how it can make you feel quite stuck, actually, quite downtrodden, quite entrenched, and how it might begin to feel like there's not much hope.
我必须承认，我非常喜欢亚马逊上的这个系列节目，叫做《克拉克森的农场》（Clarkson's Farm）。现在，如果你不是杰里米·克拉克森（Jeremy Clarkson）的粉丝，也许此时不要被吓退，因为这老实说是我看过的最喜欢的系列节目之一。我发现近距离观察农业、农场社群以及其中出现的问题是如此有趣。但当然，我们所知道的是，农民和从事农业行业的人的自杀率也被报道高于平均水平。这会是为什么呢？
I have to confess that I absolutely love this series on Amazon called Clarkson's Farm. Now, in case you're not a Jeremy Clarkson's fan, perhaps don't be put off at this stage because it's honestly one of the favourite series of mine that I've ever watched. I found it so interesting having a closer look at farming and the farming community and the things that crop up within it. But of course, what we know is that farmers and people working in the farming industry are also reported to have higher than average suicide rates. Why could this be?
我联系了莎伦·梅（Sharon May），她是一名训练有素的辅导员，最近获得了理学硕士学位，研究方向是农业和心理健康。让我们近距离了解一下可能在这个领域出现的一些主题、辩论、共同问题和观点。嗨，我只想欢迎莎伦·梅来到播客。嗨，莎伦。嗨，你好吗？欢迎来到莎伦·梅的播客。嗨，莎伦。嗨，你好吗？非常好，谢谢。谢谢你的问候。现在你已经提交了硕士研究论文，感觉怎么样？一种巨大的解脱感。我觉得它还没完全沉淀下来。总有一种挥之不去的想法，觉得还有别的事是我应该做的，但你知道的，我会习惯的。
I reached out to Sharon May, who is a trained counsellor and has done an MSc recently, looking into farming and mental health. Let's take a closer look for some of the themes and debates and common issues and perspectives that might come up in this area. Hi, I just want to welcome along Sharon May to the podcast. Hi, Sharon. Hi, how are you doing welcome along Sharon May to the podcast. Hi, Sharon. Hi, how are you doing? Really well, thank you. Thanks for asking. How are you feeling now that you've handed in your research for your master's? A big sense of relief. I don't think it's quite hit me yet. There's always that niggly thought that there's something else I should be
是的，是的，绝对的。而作为一个学者的属性就是，你可能比想象中更快地开始新的学习。是的，所以显然，希望这样说没问题：你自己就身处农业之中，你嫁入了一个农场社群、一个农场家庭，你现在做了一项研究，探讨作为一名农场主的妻子是什么体验。你能给我们讲讲，为为什么心理健康甚至会成为农业中一个讨论的话题设定一下背景吗？如果可以的话？好的，当然。我的意思是，人们经常抛出一个统计数据，即从事农业的人的自杀率远高于普通人群。不幸的是，这是自杀率最高的职业之一。我认为近年来关于原因的研究已经大大加速了，这是非常有必要的。究竟是什么原因导致农业对心理健康造成如此巨大的压力，有太多的促成因素了
doing, but you know, I'll get used to it. it yes yes absolutely and the uh the nature of being an academic is that you might well start studying sooner than you imagine yeah so obviously I hope it's okay to say that you are immersed in farming yourself you married into a farming community in a farming family um and you have now done research looking at what it's like to be a farmer's wife could you tell us a little bit set the context really for why mental health is even a conversation in farming if that's okay? Yeah sure I mean it's often touted as a statistic that the suicide rates for those in farming are much higher than the general population. And it's one of the occupations with the highest suicide rates, unfortunately. I think the research into why has accelerated massively in recent years, which it's needed to do. There's so many contributing factors to why agriculture takes such a strain on mental
在做，但你知道的，我会习惯的。是的，是的，完全是这样，作为一名学者的性质意味着你很可能比想象的更早开始研究。是的，显然希望这样说没问题：你自己也深深融入了农业，你嫁入了一个农业社区和农业家庭，嗯，你现在做了研究，探讨身为农场主的妻子是什么体验。你能跟我们聊聊，为为什么心理健康在农业领域会成为一个话题设定一下背景吗，如果可以的话？好的，当然。我的意思是，经常有这样一个统计数据被提及：农业从业人员的自杀率远高于普通人群。不幸的是，这也是自杀率最高的职业之一。我认为近年来关于原因的研究有了巨大的加速，这是必须要做的事情。导致农业对心理健康造成如此大压力的因素实在太多了
health but I think the interesting thing is that it doesn't just affect the principal farmer it has a ripple effect into into those around you know partners families that sort of thing as well because the nature of it is that it's a family business very often so it affects more than that one person but that one person is the linchpin for a lot of the pressure I think. Thank you and yeah I'm sort of racking my brains a little bit thinking about some of my learning for kind of this during my career and remembering some kind of theories that maybe it's not necessarily about the number of people attempting to end their own life, but it's about the people that manage to do that.
健康，但我觉得有趣的是，它不仅会影响主要的农场主，还会对周围的人产生连锁反应，比如伴侣、家人等等，因为它的性质通常是一个家族企业，所以受影响的不止那一个人，但那个人往往承载了很大一部分压力，我认为是这样的。谢谢。是的，我在脑海中搜索并回想我在职业生涯中积累的一些经验，想起了一些理论，也许这不一定关乎企图结束自己生命的人数，而是关乎那些真正成功这样做的人。
And actually in farming populations, people have got access to perhaps more space, more seclusion and more kind of violent means. Is that still a current theme? It's an interesting question to ask because I think a lot of people put it down to oh it's got a high rate of suicide because of the access to lethal means you know particularly firearms and things like that. Unfortunately it just means that those who attempt tend to complete. I think suicide statistics in their own are an interesting measurable way of assessing mental health in an industry but they don't take into account those who don't attempt suicide or those who have thought
实际上，在农民群体中，人们可能拥有更多的空间、更隐蔽的环境和更多样化的暴力手段。这仍然是一个当前的话题吗？这是一个有趣的问题，因为我认为很多人把它归咎于“哦，它的自杀率很高，因为更容易接触到致命手段，特别是枪支之类的东西”。不幸的是，这意味着那些尝试自杀的人往往会付诸行动。我认为自杀统计数据本身是评估一个行业心理健康的一种有趣的、可衡量的方式，但它们没有把那些没有尝试自杀的人，或者那些考虑过
about suicide but haven't attempted it and they don't take into account all those people who are struggling on a day-to-day basis with mental health issues um so whilst it is an interesting statistic to use to kind of illustrate the prevalence of mental health in just um in farming i think it i think it's just the tip of a very large iceberg to be fair yeah i agree and i think sort of thinking back on everybody i've ever assessed really it's very rare that someone hasn't told me that I've either attempted to end their own life or certainly been very close to it and of course I'm a skewed population because I'm a qualified clinical psychologist having worked in trauma services but I think this is this is endemic and I guess we're talking specifically about men today even for a man to be in a service, seeing a therapist and turning
自杀但没有付诸行动的人考虑在内，也没有把所有那些每天都在与心理健康问题挣扎的人考虑在内，嗯，所以虽然这是一个有趣的统计数据，可以用来说明心理健康在农业中的普遍性，但我觉得这其实只是冰山一角，说实话。是的，我同意。而且回想我评估过的所有人，真的，极少有人没有告诉我他们曾试图结束自己的生命，或者肯定非常接近那样做。当然，我的样本偏向于特定人群，因为我是一名合格的临床心理学家，曾在创伤服务机构工作过，但我认为这是普遍存在的。我想我们今天专门在谈论男性，即便对一个男性来说，要进入一个服务机构、看治疗师并定期出勤
up regularly is kind of hard. And I guess that's even harder in farming where, you know, we're putting barriers in place. If we're asking people to come into clinic, you know, don't wear your wellies, you know, don't be too smelly, you know, all of that stuff. But also how do you get cover to do that? How do you begin to tell people, maybe, maybe you're just a lone farmer also how do you get cover to do that how do you begin to tell people maybe maybe you're just a lone farmer how do you begin to to have the space to do that Sharon? I think I think one of the biggest barriers to um sort of help seeking when when farmers are struggling with their mental health is that self-stigmatization you know generalizing massively but they're they're a practical logical person and um they're used to be able to fix things you know if something's broken they find a way to fix it even if it's
也是一件难事。我想在农业领域这就更难了，因为你知道，我们在设置种种障碍。如果我们要求人们来到诊所，你知道，不要穿雨靴，不要身上有太大的气味，所有这些。但你又如何能找到人替班来做这件事呢？你如何开始向别人开口，也许，也许你只是一个独行农户？你也如何开始找到空间去做这件事呢，莎伦？我想，当农民们在心理健康方面苦苦挣扎时，阻碍他们寻求帮助的最大障碍之一就是自我污名化。虽然这是极大的概括，但他们是一群务实、合乎逻辑的人，习惯于解决问题，如果有什么东西坏了，他们就会想办法修好，哪怕是一个
a botched job you know they tie it up with a piece of baler twine until it works um emotional stuff doesn't work like that and i find i think they find that really destabilizing and see that as a bit of a failure. It's not helped by the masculine stereotypes that go along with farming, as with a lot of other masculine based industries. And then you've got the sort of the work ethic that is born from necessity, but becomes a bit of a badge of honour you know I haven't taken a day off the farm in you know six years you know plus the practicalities of you know not being able to step away at certain times of year or certain times of the day that sort of thing so it there's a lot of things in the way before someone can say I need help primarily admitting it to themselves then admitting it to other people, then actually seeking the professional services that they might need. Geographic isolation always
拙劣的修补，你知道的，他们会用一捆干草绳把它捆起来，直到它能运作。情感上的事情却并非如此，我觉得他们发现这一点非常具有颠覆性，并将其视为某种失败。与农业相伴的男性气概刻板印象对此也无济于事，这就像许多其他以男性为主导的行业一样。然后你还有那种由现实需求催生、却变成了一种荣誉勋章的工作伦理，你知道的，“我已经六年没离开过农场休假一天了”，再加上某些季节或某些时段根本无法抽身的实际情况。因此，在一个人能够说出“我需要帮助”之前，有太多的阻碍横亘在前：首先要向自己承认，然后向其他人承认，最后才是去寻找他们可能需要的专业服务。地理上的孤立总是
used to be a big factor because, you know, literally stepping off the farm. COVID, if it's done anything, has proved that actually you can do a lot of that from the comfort of your own home. But still, then there's the element of privacy you know your home is your workplace your workplace is your home um and there's there's a lot of things that just generally get in the way of kind of being able to take that step forward I think yeah absolutely and I have to confess I might be profess I'm not sure um to being a big fan of Clarkson's farm and that feels like it's illuminated some areas i'd never considered you know even you know the maths element of how can we get profit out of this when there's actually very very hard the margins are so reliant upon the seasons but also upon
过去是一个很大的因素，因为，字面意义上讲，就是离不开农场。如果说新冠疫情做成了什么事，那就是证明了其实你完全可以在舒适的家中完成很多事情。但即便如此，这里仍然存在隐私的元素，你知道，你的家就是你的工作场所，你的工作场所就是你的家，有很多因素在普遍阻碍着人们迈出那一步。我想是的，完全如此。而且我必须坦白，我可能是“克拉克森的农场”（Clarkson's Farm）的超级粉丝，这让我看到了一些我从未考虑过的领域，甚至包括诸如“如何在利润微薄、极度依赖季节以及政府补贴的情况下从中获利”的数学问题，以及那些似乎每时每刻都在变化的事情。我认为农业是一个棘手的问题，因为农场既是住所又是家园，而农场和家园让你在两端都被夹在中间。你既是生产者又是消费者。因此，当经济开始紧缩时，
kind of government subsidies as well and the kind of whether things are changing almost by the minute it seems is i think i think farming is a kind of it's a difficult one because because a farm is a home and a home and a farm that you're caught at both ends you're a producer and a consumer so when when economically things start to squeeze um the cost of living goes up but you're also getting less margin for your product. You know, the supermarkets, the big sellers are paying less for what they get from their producers and charging more to their customers. And a farmer or farming family gets stung twice in that. So economically, it's very difficult. Then you've got things like sort of global events, you know, the in Ukraine affecting fertilizer prices fuel prices that sort of thing so their their costs of
生活成本上升了，但你产品获得的利润却减少了。你知道的，超市和大卖家从生产者那里进货时支付的费用越来越少，而向消费者收取的费用却越来越高。农民或农场家庭在这两方面都受到了双重打击。所以在经济上，这是非常困难的。然后你还有诸如全球事件之类的事情，你知道，乌克兰的局势影响了化肥价格、燃料价格等等，所以他们的生产成本在上升，而他们产品获得的收入却在减少。所以在财务上，这是一个非常非常艰难的处境。而且，在天气方面有太多超出了你的控制，天气绝对能把你整垮。还有动物疾病，你知道，禽流感最近在新闻中很常见，结核病之类的，所有这些你完全无法控制的事情，都会让本就捉襟见肘的处境雪上加霜。杰瑞米·克拉克森（Jeremy Clarkson）强调了由此带来的压力。我认为在第一季播出后，很多人走到我们面前说：“哦，我们真的一无所知。”我想这也是其中的一部分。你知道，有些农民害怕——或者说不是害怕，这可能是另一个词——担心与他人交谈，因为别人根本不理解。那种文化上的孤立也客观存在。他们有一种感觉，他们可能交谈的专业人士无法理解他们工作的压力，也无法理解他们所处的困境，我认为这也造成了一种隔阂。
production are going up too as well as the amount they're getting for their product so financially it's a really really tough place to be and then there's so much out of your control in terms of the weather the weather can absolutely scuff you there's um animal disease you know uh avian flu has been in the news a lot recently tb that sort of thing can all these things that are nothing you have any control over can scupper an already very tight place that you find yourself in and i think the pressures of that were highlighted by Jeremy Clarkson. I think a lot of people came up to us after that first series in particular and said, oh, we just had no idea. And I think that's part of it, too. You know, some farmers are afraid of, well, not afraid, that's probably another word, worried about talking to people because they just don't get it there's that cultural isolation too there's a feeling that the professionals they might talk to might not get the pressures of their job or understand the situation that they're in and I think that also creates a bit of a gap.
绝对是这样。如果收听或观看节目的朋友们正在考虑如何成为农民更好的朋友、更好的家庭成员，或者如果他们是与农民合作、想要接触农民的临床医生，那么莎伦，他们能做的最重要的一件事是什么？这是一个很大的问题。嗯，我认为这很困难，因为没有多少人认识农民，就像没有多少人能去拥抱一个农民一样，事情不是那样的。但是对于那些认识的人，要给予关心。不过我认为，作为消费者，我们有责任在选择时更加小心，以便支持目前处于低谷的行业。
Absolutely and if people listening or watching to this are thinking about how they could be a better friend or a better family member to someone in farming or a better clinician if they're working with kind of farmers or wanting to engage farmers what what what's the one top thing they could do Sharon that's a big question uh I think I think it's difficult because not many people know a farmer like not many people can go and hug a farmer it doesn't work like that um but those that do you know check in but i think as as consumers we have a responsibility to be more careful about the choices we make in order to support an industry that is on its bottom
可以说是这样的。作为专业人士，灵活性是一件大事。对于我们这些习惯于在特定时间进行固定周薪时段工作的人来说，这意味着要乐于以一种稍微不同的方式工作，就像你对待轮班工人那样。我们要以开放的心态去面对它，因为农民和健康专业人员之间有时存在一定程度的不信任，因为从历史来看，无论是身体健康还是心理健康，外界对他们的行业一直缺乏这种理解。因此，作为从业者，要带着一点开放的心态去面对，明白这种信任确实需要建立。我的意思是，所有的关系都是如此，但尤其是那种关系，我认为一开始可能就不那么稳固。
so to speak at the moment and i think as professionals flexibility is a big thing which for those of us who are used to working in sort of regular weekly slots um at certain times that sort of thing it's it's being open to working in a slightly different way and the same that you would, I don't know, with shift workers, that sort of stuff. To kind of go into it with an open mind about there's a certain amount of mistrust between farmers and health professionals sometimes, because historically there hasn't been that understanding of their industry in physical health as well as mental health. So kind of as a practitioner going into that sort of with a bit of an open mind, knowing that that trust really has to be established. I mean, it does with all relationships, but particularly with that one, I think it's probably shaky to start with.
如果一个农民出现并要求提供心理健康支持，他们是真的非常需要心理健康支持。你知道，有轶事证据表明，如果一个农民出现在急诊室，他可能真的很受伤。请认真对待他，或者他病得很重。我认为心理健康也是如此。绝对是这样。而且我们在思考，是否可以相应地在我们的服务中优先考虑关键工作者。并且，我认为克拉克森的农场做得很好的另一件事，是凸显了农业中可能存在的真正的快乐。实际上，那些平静的时刻，那些你与自然合而为一的时刻，确实向我们展示了农业的魅力，不是吗？我想这绝对是真的。我的意思是，大多数人从事农业是因为他们对它有着热爱，
And if a farmer turns up asking for mental health support, they really need mental health support. You know, there's anecdotal evidence that, you know, if a farmer turns up in A&E, he's probably really injured. Take him seriously or he's really sick. And I think it's the same with mental health too. Absolutely. And thinking about whether we can kind of prioritise as key worker, you know, accordingly in our services. And, you know, I think another thing that Clarkson's Farm has done quite well is highlight this real joy possible in farming as well. And actually, those still moments, the moments where you're just at one with nature, you know, it really does show us the appeals of farming doesn't it I think I think that's really true I mean most people are in farming because they have an affinity
因为他们热爱这种生活方式，热爱这项工作，热爱动物。如果你和一个患有抑郁症的普通公众交谈，你会告诉他们去大自然中走走，呼吸新鲜空气，做一些体力活，所有这些事情就像是农业的完美契合——勾选，勾选，勾选。但这几乎就像是其他事情带来的压力正在阻止这一切发生一样。你知道，这本该是一种健康、吸引人的生活方式，但外部压力如此之大，以至于目前很难去享受它。在间隙里你确实能得到那些美好的片刻，这就是为什么那些仍在耕作的人依然在坚持耕作。是的，绝对如此。非常感谢你今天抽出时间，莎伦。我认为这为那些可能与农民合作或希望与农民合作的人阐明了一些非常重要的考虑因素。
for it because they love the lifestyle they love the job they love the animals um and if you were if you were talking to a member of a public who was suffering with depression you'd tell them to get out in nature get some fresh air you know do something physical all these things that like farming tick tick tick uh but it's it's almost like the pressure of the other stuff is preventing that from happening you know it should be a wholesome engaging lifestyle but the the external pressures are such that at the moment it's very hard to enjoy it you do get those bits in between for sure and that's why those who still farm still farm yeah absolutely thank you so much for your time today Sharon I think this has illuminated some really important considerations for people who might be working with farmers or or would like to work with farmers
非常感谢你抽空接受采访。不客气，这是我的荣幸。谢谢。非常感谢莎伦抽出时间，并为我们照亮了这个如此重要的领域。如果你自己从事农业，或者从事心理健康工作，希望这能为你提供一些有趣的见解，以及思考如何让所有人都能获得心理健康关怀的方法。但是我们已经开始拼凑出一个叙事：实际上，要让男性走进传统心理健康服务机构的大门是很难的。这就是为什么我真的很想去思考，到底有什么是存在的，能够
thank you so much for your time. You're welcome. It's been a pleasure. Thank you. Thank you so much to Sharon for your time and for illuminating us into this area that's so important. If you are in farming yourself or if you're working in mental health, hopefully that gives you some interesting insight and some ways to help think working in mental health. Hopefully that gives you some interesting insight and some ways to help think about making mental health care accessible to all. But we're already beginning to piece together a narrative that actually it's tricky to get men through the door of a traditional mental health service. And so that's why I really wanted to think about what is out there that could
成为带来改变的差异，或者可以成为带来改变的关键。我与Men's Sheds UK的首席执行官查理·贝瑟（Charlie Bethel）进行了交谈，探讨他的组织如何能够并且正在成为为男性带来改变的力量。嗨，查理，欢迎来到播客节目。非常感谢你抽出时间与我交谈。谢谢，谢谢你邀请我。给我们讲讲男士sheds（男士工坊/车棚）以及为什么它如此强大。所以男士工坊是男性的安全空间，嗯，这是一个男性可以去创造、连接、或者嗯，仅仅是交流、仅仅是聊天的地方，正如我所说的那样。大多数男士工坊都是木工车间，但他们也会做金属加工、3D打印，他们会做
be the difference that is making the difference or could be the difference that makes the difference. I chatted with Charlie Bethel, the CEO of Men's Sheds UK, thinking about how his organisation can be and is becoming a difference that can make the difference for men. Hi Charlie, welcome along to the podcast. Thank you so much for taking the time to talk with me. Thank you, thank you for inviting me. Tell us a little bit about men's sheds and why that is so powerful. So men's sheds are safe spaces for men um and it's somewhere where men can go to create or to connect or to um just just just communicate just just talk as i say and um the majority of men's sheds are woodworking shops um but they'll do metal work they'll do 3d printing they'll do
各种各样的事情。然后我们有一些工坊只是播放音乐，我们有一个工坊是一个养鸡场，所以他们去那里的那一群男士会去照顾鸡。使用“男士”这个词其实有点……它不一定是完全公平的，因为现在有很多工坊也有女性参与，但总的来说，总是有一个纯男性的环节，而正是这一部分真正发挥了作用，对去那里的男性产生了神奇的效果。然后可能也会有混合环节或纯女性环节，而且也有纯女性的工坊，但我们在名称中保留了“男士”，因为我们是为了男士的健康而存在的，我们的愿景是更健康、更快乐的男士。是的，这也会对社会产生连锁反应，对围绕这些男性的家人和朋友也是如此。
all sorts of things and then we've got some sheds that just play music and we've got a shed that is a chicken shed so they just go the group of men there will go and look after chickens the use of many is is a little bit it's not necessarily completely fair because a number of sheds now have women but generally there's always a men's only session and it's that piece that really works it's magical on the men that go to them um and then there may be mixed sessions or women only sessions as well and there are women only sheds um but we keep men in the title because we're there for men's health and our vision is healthier and happier men. Yeah, which has a knock-on effect for society as well, for the families and the friends around these men.
确实如此，许多来到工坊的人是因为他们的妻子把他们带到了工坊，或者他们的女儿说他们应该去工坊。不久前曾有过这样一个例子：雷丁（Reading）的一个工坊里，有一个妻子来到这里，把丈夫拖过来，说：“我要去购物，在你不注册之前别想离开。”这种情况经常发生。我们使用的一个类比是，如果你把12个男人放进一个正方形的房间里——这里是正方形这一点相当重要——并要求他们谈论自己的感受，其中6个人会立即离开，另外6个人会试图寻找房间的角。而作为男人，我们搞不懂为什么6不能塞进4个角里。然而，如果你在房间里放一台割草机，
It does, and many people that come to the shed come because their wife has taken them down to the shed or their daughters have said they should go to the shed. And there was one occasion um not so long ago where a shed in reading had a wife come down drag the husband and say i'm going shopping you're not leaving until you've signed up and and that's very often what happens and the analogy we use is that if you put 12 men in a in a square room um which is quite important that's square and ask them to talk about their feelings six will leave immediately and the other six will try to find the corners of the room and being men we can't work out that six doesn't go into four. However, if you put a lawnmower in the room and
然后说“把它修好”，两个小时后，他们就会对彼此了如指掌，因为他们会并肩工作、交谈，知道对方孩子的名字、孙辈的名字、有什么病痛。这不仅从心理健康的角度，而且从身体健康的视角产生了更深远的影响。有很多这样的例子：工坊成员并没有联合起来指责某人，而是巧妙地劝说对方去看医生并解决某种病痛。你知道的，这甚至让失明的人重见光明。你知道，有一些人失去了视力，而来到工坊却促使他们去看医生并解决了这些问题。
say fix it, after two hours they will know each other intimately because they will work shoulder to shoulder, they'll talk, they'll know the names of their children, their grandchildren, what ails them and it has further impact not only from a mental health perspective but also from a physical health perspective and there's lots of examples where shedders have not ganged up on somebody but subtly convinced them to go to the doctors and sort out an ailment you know and it's really seen blind people see you know there's been some people that have lost their sight and actually going to the shed has made them then go to the doctors and resolve those problems.
而且，是的，我们可以向你提供许多关于自杀、焦虑和抑郁的统计数据，证明它比你在NHS（国民健康体系）能拿到的任何药片都更有效。是的，这就是包容性，不是吗？被看到、成为某事物的一部分、感到被倾听、觉得自已无足轻重——哦不，是觉得自己很重要。我们对抑郁症的许多认知恰恰与此相反。
And, yeah, there are a number of stats we can give you on suicide or on anxiety and depression that it's better than any pill you can get on the NHS. Yeah, it's the inclusion, isn't it? And the being seen and being part of something and feeling heard and feeling like you matter. And so much of what we know about depression can be the opposite of that.
是的。这就是目标感。所以你去工坊是为了给自己做点东西，你去工坊是为了给家人或朋友做点东西，然后因为你在工坊里可以独处，你不一定非得和其他工坊成员一起工作，但当你为当地火车站或当地学校制作东西时，就会有一种目标感。
Yeah. And it's the sense of purpose. So you go to a shed to make something for yourself, you go to the shed to make something for your family or for friends, and then because you can be on your own in the shed, you don't have to be working with the other shedders, but then there's that sense of purpose when you're making things for the local train station or local school.
最近有一个工坊制作了17个——最近，去年，为一所学校制作了17个木琴。不，是钟琴。我总是搞错，显然它们是不同的。但是他们——不幸的是孩子们后来听了他们演奏，但这只是给他们带来了一种自豪感和目标感，这非常重要。我，你知道的，当人们谈到马斯洛的需求层次时，这种目标感应该放在核心和显眼的位置，因为它能带来所有的不同。我们有人对我们说：“我当时面临抉择，
One shed recently made 17, recently last year, made 17 xylophones for school. No, glockenspiels. I always get that wrong, apparently they're different. But they, and unfortunately for the children they then played them to them, but it's just that sense of pride that it gives them and that sense of purpose which is really important and I, you know, when people talk about, you know, Maslow's hierarchy, you know, that sense of purpose should be in there front and centre because it makes all the difference. We have people say to us, you know, I had a choice,
要么去男士工坊，要么在沙发上等死。”事实确实如此。雷德卡（Redcar）有一个家伙，这曾登上过报纸。如果你知道的话，请记住我们在这里谈论的是男性，所以他们能够真正敞开心扉并在事后讲述这些故事是一个巨大的步骤，表明了他们感到多么安全。嗯，有个家伙当时正要去海边结束自己的生命，嗯，在路上他偶遇了一个人，那个人开始跟他谈论男士工坊的事情，非常热情。他不知道这个家伙为什么会走这条小路。
go to the men's shed or die by sofa. And it genuinely is that. And there was one guy from Redcar car this was in the newspaper and if you know kind of bear in mind we're talking about men here so them actually opening up and telling these stories afterwards is a huge step and shows how safe they feel um one guy was going to the sea to end his life and um on the way there he bumped into somebody who started talking to him about the men's shed was He was really enthusiastic. He didn't know why this guy was walking down this path.
那个人转过身，和他一起去参观了工坊，从那以后他就再也没有回去做傻事了。我们一次又一次地听到这个故事。这就是关于那个安全的环境。可能需要一个人花五、六次才敢走进工坊的大门。这就像他们在踩点一样。但当他们真正走进来时，他们发现了一种非常无侵入性、不逼问的文化，一个让他们能够茁壮成长的环境。正如我所说，这里有大量的故事。我们做过一次调查。
The guy turned around, went to see the shed with him, and he hasn't gone back since. And we hear that story time and time again. And it is about that safe environment. It might take somebody five, six times to walk through the door of a shed. It's like they're casing out the joint. But when they do come through, they find a very non-invasive, non-questioning culture, an environment where they can thrive. And as I say, there are plenty of stories. We did a survey.
目前全英国有1,180个工坊。我们做了一项调查，询问了许多关于健康和福祉的问题。其中一个问题是：“你认为你的工坊曾拯救过一条生命吗？”25%的人回答“是”。有178个回复。所以这是一个相当合理的比例。25%的人回答“是”。
There's 1,180 sheds across the UK at the moment. And we did a survey asking a number of questions around health and wellbeing. And one was, do you believe your shed has saved a life? And 25% said yes. There's 178 replies. So quite a reasonable chunk. 25% said yes.
14%的人回答“是的，我们相信是这样”。在那些回答“是”的人中，有些人说：“是的，其中也包括我。”这里并没有问你以后是否可能会有那种结束自己生命的想法。这是一个直接的回答：“是的，这拯救了我的生命。”如果一个工坊只做了一件事并且做成了这件事，那么整个运动就完全值得了。绝对是这样。
And 14% said, yes, we believe so. And some of those 25% said, yeah, and that includes me. And there wasn't a question of like, that you might've felt that way later on to end your life. It was direct, yes, this has saved my life. And if a shed has done one thing and it's done that, then the whole movement's been worthwhile. Absolutely.
这是令人难以置信的强大力量。要获得那些你所知道的真正的案例研究例子，哦，这是显而易见的，它对人们来说简直就是改变人生。如果有人一生中从未拿过锯子、凿子或扳手，这有关系吗？除了他们的手指之外——不，不，没关系。许多去工坊的人以前什么也没做过。所以工坊负责人会懂一些，因为他们只是对正在发生的事情进行一些监督，比如开门。大多数工坊，如果不是全部，都会先进行一些审查，比如：你知道如何使用这台机器吗？好吧，好的，那我来教你怎么做，并对人员进行培训，让他们通过机械和设备的考核并获得操作许可。工坊里最危险的工具可能是美工刀，
It's incredibly powerful stuff. And to get those you know those real case study examples it's oh it's obvious it's just life-changing for people does it matter if somebody's never picked up a saw or a chisel or a spanner in their life only for their fingers um no no it doesn't matter um many people that go to sheds won't have done anything before. So a shed leader will have done because they just keep a bit of oversight of what's going on, like open the door. Most sheds, if not all, will do some vetting first in terms of, you know, do you know how to use this machine? Right, OK, well, let me show you how to do it and put people through and sign them off on on machinery and equipment the most dangerous tool in a workshop is probably the stanley knife
但是，嗯，不，如果人们以前从未做过任何事情，工坊会从简单的项目开始。比如鸟屋。如果说妇女协会（WI）代表的是果酱和耶路撒冷（传统英国元素），那么男士工坊代表的就是鸟屋和茶。所以这里制作了大量的鸟屋，还有大量的木工车床来制作碗，这是一个相对容易学习的过程。对于不同水平的人，有不同的技术。你知道，如果你的手部握力不够强，你可以使用其他辅助设备。有些人去那儿只是在工坊里喝杯茶，他们实际上并没有参与任何制作，但他们融入了社群。所以，你知道的，这没关系。我的意思是，在另一端——哦抱歉，我应该说，我去参观过的第一个工坊里，
but um no the sheds will start off with simple projects for people if they've never done anything before and so bird boxes so if the wi is jam and jerusalem men's sheds are bird boxes and tea um so there are lots of bird boxes made but there's lots of wood turning to turn a bowl it's um you know it's a relatively easy thing to learn um and there are different techniques for people at different levels and you know if your hand grip isn't as strong you can use the other devices you can use and some people just go and just have a cup of tea in the shed they don't they don't actually engage in anything so um but they engage in the community so so you know it doesn't it doesn't matter i mean at the other end um well sorry i should say the first shed i ever went to
有一个女士在那里制作一个鸟食台，这个鸟食台上面突出的钉子，简直可以从100码外刺穿一只知更鸟，这太吓人了。我的学位是设计专业，所以我看着它心想：我真的想来这样一个地方工作，或者为这样一个慈善机构工作吗？但是她所拥有的快乐，以及其他工坊成员看到她创作时所感受到的快乐，简直是无法估量的。我的意思是，那太棒了。然后在另一端，你会看到人们为教堂后部制作饰带，也就是木雕，你会看到最令人难以置信的艺术和设计作品被创造出来。还有圣诞老人雪橇的火车，
see there was a lady in there making a um bird table and the nails that were sticking out of this bird table would have been they would have impaled a robin from 100 yards and it was frightening and my degree was design so I'm looking at it thinking do I really want to come and work somewhere like this or for charity like this but the joy that she had and the joy that the other shedders had seeing her create that was just immeasurable I mean that was fantastic and then at the other end of the scale, you see people making freezes for the backs of churches, so wooden carvings, and you see the most incredible pieces of art and design that are created and, you know, trains for the Father Christmas sleighs,
你知道的，当他降落并必须绕着当地街道行驶时，他们为他制造这些。他们可以创造的范围非常广泛。但你得从钉下一枚钉子开始。我只见过工坊里有一个人完全不会使用工具。说那是去参观的前首相可能对我来说有点太政治化了。但是，是的，工坊成员确实非常乐于帮助提携其他人。这是一个真正没有竞争的环境，他们通常会把自我意识留在门外。
you know, when he lands and he has to go around the local streets, that they create those for him. It's a huge range of things that they can create. But you start one nail at a time. There's only one person I've seen in a shed not be able to use a tool. And it'd probably be too political for me to say that that was the former prime minister visiting one. So, but, yeah, no, the shedders really do help bring on other people it's really it's a non-competitive environment there's there's that they leave egos at the door generally
是的，这里有适合所有人的空间。即使你第一次相处得不是很好，我们都可以成长，我们都可以开发新的技能。这和艺术不同。我记得我的一位资助者对我说过的话，她训斥了我，因为我说：“你知道的，这和艺术课没有太大区别。”她说：“不，不，不，不。在艺术课上，你可能坐在康斯特布尔（Constable）或巴勃罗·毕加索（Pablo Picasso）旁边，那会让你泄气的。在工坊里，你只需要打磨木头就能获得满足感。”所以她是我们众多拥护者之一。太棒了。加入和参加它们都是免费的吗？
yeah and there's scope for everybody even if you don't get on very well the first time we can all grow we can all develop new skills yeah and it's different to say art i remember this one of my um one of our funders saying to me telling me off because I said you know it's not too dissimilar to art classes and she said no no no no in an art class you might be sat next to Constable or next to Pablo Picasso um you know that would dishearten you in a shed you can just be sanding down the wood and get the satisfaction of it so she was one of our very many advocates amazing and are they all free for people to join and come along too so they vary um so some sheds give us for a donation other sheds might say it's a pound
情况各不相同。有些工坊只接受捐赠，有些工坊可能会说每次活动一英镑，还有些工坊可能是一百英镑的年费，然后你可以分期支付。但通常这意味着，你知道的，通过申报进行经济状况调查，如果有人遇到困难，工坊总是会想方设法让他们留下来。而且我认为我交谈过的每一个工坊都不会把费用作为加入的障碍。我们英国男士工坊联合会的创始人在卡姆登工坊（Camden Shed）创立了它，第一个走进大门的人当时一周靠五英镑生活，因为他和当时被称为DHS（福利机构）的部门吵过架。他在自己修鞋，在做所有这些活动。三个月后，他对他们说：
a session um other sheds might have a it's a you know 100 pound for a year's membership and then you can pay that over that time but it's usually mean they you know by declaration means test it and if somebody's struggling the shed will always find a way of keeping them in there and and i think every shed i've ever spoken to would not put um the cost um as an obstacle for somebody joining and and our first the founder the UK Men's Shed Association's founder that was was at Camden Shed set up Camden Shed and the first guy who came through the door was living on five pound a week because he had an argument with the DHS whatever they were called at the time he was mending his own shoes he was doing all of those activities and after three months he said to them
“你知道吗，要不是有这个地方，我早就死了。”这是因为他们不收费，而且他们非常热情。那时他在生活中没有别的地方可去，而现在他不再去那个工坊了，他有了一份工作，有了住处。这是一个非常不同的故事，
do you know I'd have been dead if it wasn't for this place and it was because they didn't charge but because they were so welcoming as well and he had nothing else in his life to go to at that time he no longer goes to that shed he's got a job he's got somewhere to live it's a very different story
因为工坊给了他信心。所以，是的，这是一种令人难以置信的力量。你知道，它被称为“不敢说出名字的疗法”，男士工坊——我更喜欢叫它“男人的软游乐场”，但它确实具有那种略带调侃的冲击力。所以，是的。这是一个个案处理、因工坊而异的基础，但财务状况绝不是不去的理由，因为总有办法解决。如果你需要工坊，那么工坊也需要你。人们如何找到——抱歉，抱歉，你请。
because the shed gave him that confidence um and so yeah it's it's an incredible power you know and it's been coined as therapy that dare not speak your name speak its name the men's shed i prefer soft play for men but um it it really does have that kind of kind of cheeky impact as well so yes yeah so it's a case-by-case shed by shed basis but finances are not a reason to not go because there's you know something can always be done if if if you need the shed then the shed needs you how do people find sorry sorry you you go no no, the only obstacle is that sheds are at capacity at the moment. So we're trying to help sheds with training and finding other premises
不，不，唯一的障碍是目前工坊已经满员了。所以我们正试图通过培训和寻找其他场所来帮助工坊开设更多的分部，因为很多工坊都有等待名单，这本不该发生。他们正试图在可能的情况下开放更多的天数。但许多工坊一周营业五天，并正在考虑是否开展晚间或周末活动，工坊网络中也开始出现这种情况。所以这可能是目前存在的唯一障碍。好的。那么人们如何找到离他们最近的工坊，或者试着把自己加入等待名单，或者看看是否有空位呢？
and more sheds to open because a lot of sheds have waiting lists, which should never happen. They're trying to open more days where they can. But a lot of sheds are open five days a week and looking at well do we do evenings do we do weekends and that's starting to happen around the shed network as well so that's probably the only barrier that's there at the moment okay and how do people find their closest shed or try and get themselves on a waiting list or see if there's space available? So there's an app on our website, which is mensheds.org.uk. There's a find a shed tool.
我们的网站上有一个应用程序，网址是 mensheds.org.uk。上面有一个“寻找工坊”的工具。你输入你的邮政编码。记得点击搜索，这正是我每次使用时经常出的问题。然后它就会显示出所有当地的工坊。它会提供他们的联系方式，无论是电话号码还是电子邮件地址。另外，如果你所在的地区没有工坊，我们也会在那里尽力帮助创建更多的工坊。但工坊需要由当地社区的男性和女性来创建，因为只有这样它才能具有可持续性。有一些工坊项目是某人建立了一个工坊并付费请人来运营的。
You type in your postcode. You remember to click search, which is always my issue when I do it. And then it comes up with all the local sheds. And it will have their contact details, whether that's a phone number or an email address. But also, if there isn't a shed in your area, we're there to try and help create more sheds. But sheds need to be created by the men and women in their local community because then it becomes sustainable. There are a number of shed projects where somebody sets up a shed and pays for somebody to run it.
但它们通常不太具有可持续性，即使它们持续了10年，最后还是会崩溃，我们现在经常看到这种情况。然而，如果你从那个社区开始建立它——我们对此提供了帮助——你就会看到一个非常强大、可持续的工坊，拥有它继续存在、发展和壮大所需的所有收入。有些工坊拥有超过200名会员。好的。听起来你们确实在改变生命。如果人们对此感动并希望向男士工坊联合会捐款，他们可以吗？可以的。
But they usually, they're not very sustainable and even if they've lasted 10 years they then just collapse where and we're seeing this quite a lot now whereas if you build it from that community and you know we helped to do that you see a very strong sustainable uh shed with all the income that it needs to continue to exist and to grow and develop. And some sheds have got over 200 members. Okay. Well, it really does sound like you're changing lives. And if people are touched by this and want to donate to the Men's Sheds Association, can they? Yes.
同样，在我们的网站上，有机会进行捐赠，或者直接发邮件与我们交谈，特别是如果那个功能再次出现故障的话。但是，是的，他们可以这样做，或者只是发邮件与我们交谈，特别是如果那个功能再次了解我们和我们正在做的事情。因此，可能会有一些你想要支持的当地工坊。在社交媒体上的男士工坊，人们可以在社交媒体上关注你们吗？是的，我们在所有的社交媒体平台上都有账号，虽然我不知道怎么用。是的，不，我们在领英（LinkedIn）、推特（Twitter）、Instagram上都有。我会确保把它放在屏幕上和节目简介里，人们可以关注。非常感谢你抽出时间，以及你和你的组织
Again, on our website, there is an opportunity to do that or just to email in and speak to us, particularly if that function is broken again. But, yeah, they could do that or just to email in and speak to us particularly if that function is broken again but yeah no they could do that but just give us a call and find out more about us and what we're doing so there may be some local sheds that you want to support and amend sheds on social media can people follow you on socials yes we're on all of the things that are on social media which I don't know how to use but yes no we're on linkedin twitter instagram i'll make sure it's on i'll make sure it's on on the screen and in the show notes and people can follow thank you so much for your time and for everything that you
为支持男性——事实上还有男士工坊中的女性——所做的一切。谢谢你，玛丽安。谢谢。非常感谢查理，以及我们所有的嘉宾抽出时间与我们交谈。谢谢你，玛丽安。总的来说，还要考虑如何减少男性自杀的发生率。我很想听听你对这方面的想法。你觉得这是一集有用的节目吗？它是否启发了你的思考，无论是为了你自己的心理健康还是为了你支持的其他人？如果你在YouTube上观看，请在评论区告诉我。请务必订阅、点赞、分享，分享给你共事的团队，无论他们是在临床工作、在建筑工地、在农场还是在酒吧。如果你是通过MP3收听的，
and your organization do to support men and in fact women in men's sheds thank you marianne thank you thank you so much to charlie and indeed all of our guests for their time in speaking with Thank you, Marianne. generally, but also to think about reducing the incidence of male suicide specifically. I would love your thoughts around this. Have you found this a useful episode? Has it inspired your thinking, either for your own mental health or that of someone else that you support? Please do let me know in the comments if watching on YouTube. Please do subscribe, like, share, share to the teams that you're working with, be they clinical or be they on a building site, in a farm or just down the pub. If you're listening as an MP3,
请考虑在Spotify和Apple Podcasts上进行评分和评论。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。能够与你交谈并为你带来这些非常重要的内容是我的荣幸和快乐。如果你想与我联系，请加入我的Facebook群组：The Aspiring Psychologist Community, with Dr. Marianne Trent（有玛丽安·特伦特博士陪伴的有志心理学家社区）。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。保重。
please do consider rating and reviewing on Spotify and Apple Podcasts. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent. It is my privilege and pleasure to speak with you and to bring you this really important content. If you would like to connect with me, please do come and join my Facebook group, The Aspiring Psychologist Community, with Dr. Marianne Trent. Thank you so much for being part
通过这个播客，你离获得资格又近了一步，这就是《有志心理学家播客》（The Aspiring Psychologist Podcast），我是玛丽安博士。我叫亚娜（Jana），是一名见习心理健康从业者。我读了《临床心理学家集锦》（Clinical Psychologist Collective）这本书。我发现里面所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历都非常有趣。成为临床心理学家的途径竟然有这么多，这让我感到惊讶，而且没有完美的途径可以成为其中一员，这让我充满信心：不，我没有做错，并减轻了我自己的压力。因此，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。
of my world. Take care. with this podcast that you're sad you'll be on your way to being qualified it's the aspiring psychologist podcast with dr marianne My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist it just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay.
但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。这一集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但相信我，一旦开始读，你就放不下这本书。这个节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。